je ne suis pas venu effectivement faire
du développement personnel ou l'apologie
d'une quelconque success story
moi je m'appelle Eddy mocurrent j'ai 33
ans j'ai donc écrit plusieurs romans
trois romans exactement marcheurs warm
blue 1 blue 2 qui sont tous des romans
de l'imaginaire littérature de gens ce
qu'on appelle science-fiction fantaisie
fantastique
et
c'est ça qui va m'intéresser tout
particulièrement aujourd'hui vous
montrer l'envers du décor le revers de
la médaille finalement comment on écrit
un texte les galères d'un jeune auteur
on va enlever un peu le phare de tout ça
on va regarder comment ça se passe pour
de vrai et puis j'ose croire finalement
quand vous exposant ces difficultés ceux
qui souhaiteraient se lancer dans
l'aventure de l'écriture finalement
découvrirez aussi on partagerait quelque
chose oui c'est pas seulement de la
poudre de perlimpinpin ou quoi que ce
soit c'est difficile effectivement et de
manière plus générale partager cette
expérience avec vous
alors
quelle qualité requise selon moi
pour écrire
alors ça va peut-être vous surprendre
mais la première c'est l'ego
parce qu'il vous en faut évidemment de
l'ego vous allez consacrer
un an deux ans parfois beaucoup plus
toutes ces années à écrire un texte ça
va être difficile et vous allez lancer
en pleine place publique
ça peut être super violent les retours
j'aime pas c'est nul ça m'intéresse pas
je lis pas
donc c'est forcément à ce moment là que
vous allez en prendre plein la fraise et
si vous avez pas un peu d'ego ça va être
très compliqué
Alfred de Musset disait l'orgueil c'est
la probité du pauvre et la grandeur des
rois
et je rajouterais le carburant de
l'auteur je me souviens en fac de
lettres on était tous des vies ont des
verlaines des Baudelaire en puissance et
c'est super fondamentalement parce que
ça vous donne cette énergie pour écrire
pour accepter les défis bon ça c'est
pour l'ego
il y a une autre qualité
paradoxalement qui est requise en tout
cas à mes yeux une nouvelle fois c'est
l'humilité face à la somme incroyable de
travail qui vous attend
c'est un travail titanesque de retouche
la retouche c'est
99,9% de votre travail d'auteur on
retouche encore et encore et encore et
encore comme Flaubert à la limite qui
hurlait son texte et on s'arrête jamais
de retoucher
c'est très très exigeant ça demande
beaucoup d'engagement je me souviens
l'incipit de mon de mon roman warm blue
j'ai eu besoin de six mois pour me
décider si je m'étais une virgule ou un
point virgule on est à ce niveau là de
toc et de monomania si je puis dire
ce que je mets cette virgule là non
c'est pas super alors on y pense sous la
douche je vais retoucher puis on y pense
aux toilettes puis on y pense en sa
chambre en voiture en conduisant ça ne
s'arrête jamais si vous n'êtes pas prêt
à faire ça et à retravailler votre texte
c'est pas la peine
bon là on a deux qualités qui ont été
présentées super
maintenant place aux difficultés sinon
c'est pas drôle
alors la première des difficultés c'est
que vous allez rentrer dans une fausse
remplie de lions d'ours et de serpents
le marché éditorial est impitoyable
parfois même monstrueux
je m'explique
il faut garder en tête que lorsque par
exemple j'ai voulu publier mon premier
roman j'ai toqué à la porte de 50
maisons d'édition
essuyant refuse sur refus après tout
pourquoi faire confiance à cette
illustre inconnue quelles sont les
chances pour que cette inconnue donc
fasse une TEDx
les éditeurs français n'aiment pas
forcément les jeunes auteurs
pourquoi faire confiance à ce texte mais
j'avais entendu parler est-ce que ça m'a
rapporté un peu d'argent bon très bien
donc je me suis tourné vers les
anglo-saxons ou plus précisément pour
être plus juste au Canada et chez des
Québécois
bon ils ont accepté très bien on va
tester le marché québécois et puis
ensuite on va on va lancer donc votre
livre en Europe dans plusieurs pays ça
marche très bien sauf qu'il me demande
une suite
et que cette suite finalement et ben ne
sera pas publié puisque mon éditeur me
dit tout simplement en fait on laisse
tomber deux ans et demi de travail perdu
puisqu'on ne peut pas publier comme ça
ex nihilo une suite croyez-moi c'est pas
facile à prendre dans les dents vraiment
pas l'écriture fondamentalement c'est
l'échec
quelque part tant mieux parce que si on
était un parangon de littérature on
serait forcément répétitif dans sa
perfection ou alors on finirait par
régresser
mais bon là je dis ça maintenant mais
sur le coup c'était très difficile
donc l'échec il faut absolument
antérioriser ça l'écriture est l'échec
il y a un autre un autre problème
problème ou en tout cas concurrent
l'image et oui je me souviens très très
bien j'étais invité à la Japan Touch lip
touch alors j'étais tout content
j'allais présenter mon livre
là-bas je vivais en Écosse à l'époque on
paye le billet d'avion super
et puis je vais sur le stand quelques
personnes se pressent du coup pour
signer des livres et je vois cette
horde phénoménale de gens qui vont voir
les streamers
les youtubers moi j'aime bien aussi mais
sur le coup je me dis
est-ce que j'ai choisi la bonne voie là
concrètement à quoi bon écrire si on
n'est pas lu surtout à l'ère de l'image
mais de manière générale un écrivain
concrètement qui n'est pas lu n'existe
pas un texte qui n'est pas lu n'existe
pas c'est le lecteur qui fait vivre le
texte de Marie de France jusqu'à
maintenant c'est la même chanson
et donc effectivement ce questionnement
là se pose alors on entendra toujours
dire oui mais tu comprends il faut faire
ce qui te plaît
oui mais si je suis pas lu je n'existe
pas
donc ces questions se bousculent se
mélangent puisque quand vous travaillez
2 ans et demi sur un texte il est
légitime de s'interroger finalement sur
ce qui m'a donné ensuite
alors du coup pourquoi j'écris non mais
c'est vrai parce que bon ça fait quand
même beaucoup de choses compliquées là
alors d'abord je vais reprendre un adage
médiéval que j'aime beaucoup nous sommes
des nains mais nous montons sur les
épaules de géants
quand on écrit et bien sûr moi c'est
c'est le cas évidemment depuis tout
petit
je suis nourri à la science-fiction la
fantaisie fantastique pas que cela
s'entend mais quand on écrit on a
fondamentalement l'envie de dépasser ses
maîtres c'est incroyablement orgueilleux
c'est extrêmement prétentieux mais ça
vous donne une force pour écrire et ne
jamais rien lâcher
j'ai 3 mètres en littérature
d'Anne Simons américain très francophile
qui m'a appris à construire une histoire
que moi je l'espère
dans le tech que je cite beaucoup et que
j'aime beaucoup qui m'a appris l'art du
style de la figure de style du moins je
l'espère
et j'avortis mettre absolu de la
fantaisie française qui lui m'a appris à
écrire avec élégance
du moins je l'espère
alors dépasser ces maîtres soit mais ça
ne peut pas être en soi la seule
motivation
il y a
évidemment
quelque chose
d'incroyablement grisant
lorsqu'on joue à être Dieu bah oui quand
on écrit c'est ça on est Dieu l'espace
d'un instant on a tout pouvoir
pur des murs on peut absolument tout
faire et croyez-moi c'est extrêmement
grisant
vous regardez cette lanterne qui se
balance de gauche à droite et qui laisse
des reflets comment je vais la
caractériser comment vais-je
caractériser cette ambiance créer des
ambiances
mon premier roman
est un long glissement
du polar jusqu'au fantastique donc
l'ambiance il fallait la travailler il
fallait que je fasse quelque chose de
cette lanterne qui grince et qui laisse
des lueurs de droite à gauche et là vous
êtes sur un travail quasiment de
d'expressionniste et ça c'est beau de
créer ses ambiances ces atmosphères
c'est très grisant
et puis
bon j'aime bien les adages
placerez d'opérer dirais-je pour
reprendre la fameuse expression plaire
et instruire
après marcheurs donc ce roman d'ambiance
se glissement entre le polar et le
fantastique j'ai voulu écrire un roman
d'anticipe passion très précisément la
science-fiction mais techno thriller
d'anticipation
il fallait donc que je construise ce que
pouvait être le siècle prochain
pas facile comme tâche moi je suis pas
très bon en maths et en physique du coup
il a fallu que j'aille chercher l'aide
de spécialiste chercheurs en physique
nucléaire agence spatiale européenne des
militaires des vétérinaires pour essayer
de créer un monde plausible
car l'écrivain de l'imaginaire a le
devoir absolu de rendre son histoire
crédible sinon il n'est pas lu
et donc je travaille je compile toutes
ces données est-ce que la
bioluminescence finalement peut éclairer
suffisamment une rue quelle énergie
utilisée sur Mars comment aller sur Mars
autant de questions finalement vous avez
besoin de pas mal d'aide et puis bien
sûr puisque c'est une projection de ce
que pourrait advenir de ce qui pourrait
advenir effectivement dans un siècle
vous vous doutez bien regarde la
catastrophe écologique que c'est pas
très optimiste et donc outre ce travail
de journaliste de compilation qui est
très intéressant
vous prenez le rôle du chien de garde
celui qui avertit l'air divertir et
instruire
alors bon
finalement
je parlais de
on peut tout à fait faire des séries des
films sans aucun problème et donner de
travail l'ambiance faire quelque chose
d'impressionniste jouer à être dur en
étant un réalisateur on peut tout à fait
en filmant avec une caméra plaire et
instruire selon le l'adage des du grand
siècle
il y a une chose très importante ici qui
va m'intéresser
l'écrivain et comme l'architecte
il crée des espaces des structures
communes universelles que nous que nous
pouvons traverser que nous pouvons
arpenter mais dans lesquels nous vivrons
des expériences uniques intimes
originales en un mot on lit tous la même
chose mais on ne voit pas la même chose
c'est comme ouvrir une planche de BD et
respirer mille parfums qui vous seront
propres et ça le cinéma ne l'aura pas
c'est quelque chose de très très fort
quelque chose que je ne suis pas prêt à
abandonner et qui aussi après toutes les
motivations que je vous ai ici énoncé me
pousse à écrire vous créez quelque chose
d'unique qui sera aussi unique chez la
personne qui le reçoit et
systématiquement original
bon et puis force c'est de constater
Game of Thrones Witcher the expense
Gomorra le jeu de la dame tous ces
succès toutes ces séries
sont adaptés de romans
quel meilleur scénario qu'un roman vous
avez le meilleur des screenplay ici
incroyable non une structure narrative
incroyablement efficace qui marche du
feu de dieu avec potentiellement à la
base un petit succès et une nouvelle
expérience cette fois-ci graphique que
vous allez proposer à votre public
qu'elle transformation sublime n'est-ce
pas
et donc
modestement bien sûr pour un auteur sur
cette dernière phrase je conclurai comme
la démontre aux élèves on leur explique
comment terminer un commentaire de texte
sur une ouverture et cette transition
donc avec les séries quel futur pour mes
romans et je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]